The Hollywood reporter recently wrote an article about tribewives.
It was interviewed for the article,
and I absolutely love the quote that they chose.
I wanted to be the mom I dreamed of instead of the wife he wanted.
I was searching my soul into why motherhood,
while it was something I had dreamed of since I could think,
some might say I was groomed into this life,
but that's another story. But why was I not finding the joy
that I thought I was supposed to find in motherhood?
Why did it seem like so much work?
Why was I so tired? Why was I unable to, like,
not lose my temper with my kids?
why was. Why are two year olds able to get under my skin?
You know what I mean? Like,
what's going on here that I can't keep my cool?
They're my children that I love.
What's going on? That I'm so frustrated.
I'm waking up at such anxiety and frustration levels.
And when I did some soul searching,
I realized I'm not able to mother them the way that I want.
My focus as a tribe wife is my husband and how to keep him happy.
And that means keep the kids quiet.
And that means
I don't get to mother them and enjoy them the way that I want.
I'm looking for ways to escape
and to leave the house and to do other things.
And so I realized I had To pick.
I got to that point. I had to pick my husband or my kids,
and I chose my kids.
I would rather my kids have the mother that they deserve
because I brought them into the world.
I owe that to them.
Then cling to a failing relationship
just because I brought kids into the world with him.